hey it's Justine and as you can see I'm
not in my normal video Studio setup I'm
actually in my gaming room because we're
nearing The Fall season where I tend to
spend so much more time in here playing
video games and as you can see behind me
I have a new addition to the gaming room
this is LG's New Q Ned TV and we're
going to unbox it and check it
out a baby a baby is here here so I'm
putting these legs on and something that
I noticed this is pretty unique cuz I
haven't really seen this in many TVs it
gives you the option to put the legs
here or here if you have a smaller TV
stand and that's pretty great cuz I was
actually concerned that it was not going
to fit on this desk but so far looks
like it's going to
work this is the LG 75 q80 it's a 75 in
TV with a super slim design quantum dot
Nano cell technology for great colors an
alpha 7 AI processor for for outstanding
picture sound and performance complete
with thin qai and web OS for nextg Smart
TV functionality and just a note that
depending upon where you are This TV has
a different model name in the US it's
the Q n80 and in the UK it's the Q n81
all right turning it on oh man it looks
so good okay I'm going to have a seat
just try it out just picture this type
type type working game game game game
gaming turn around game game game game
some more or I can watch some content
all right so let's watch some content
and then check out some of the
features Q anded is the latest LCD
technology combining a backlit display
with quantum dot and Nano cell
technology to deliver enhanced
brightness deeper blacks and brilliant
colors the alpha 7 AI processor allows
for precise light and color control it
enhances picture details automatic
brightness and regulates sound volume
depending on what you're watching the
alpha 7 processor also Powers dimming
Pro this is l is dimming technology that
uses deep learning algorithms to produce
sharper more natural images while
minimizing halo effect AI picture wizard
analyzes 85 million potential settings
to find the best photo settings possible
and analyzes viewers color preferences
to provide personalized display settings
but my favorite part about this TV is
how convenient it is to use the magic
remote makes it super simple to navigate
thin quue and web OS making finding
content easy the first thing that you'll
notice is how rich these colors are and
again this is a YouTube video and you
are watching this compressed so it is
kind of hard to tell unless you are
actually here in person but from all of
the TV reviews that I've done I think
you can get a pretty good sense of how
incredible this looks this really shows
you how black these blacks can get
they're so deep that when I'm looking at
this right here like it actually doesn't
even look like parts of the television
is on it's like it's completely not
illuminated and it's so impressive it
looks like part of the TV isn't even on
that this glass is just floating in
space it's so awesome you'll also notice
how bright the colors are how crisp and
how sharp everything is now these QED
TVs are A step above the LG LED TVs so
you'll definitely notice if you've ever
seen them side bys side that the Q anded
definitely has a higher vibrancy and
just even the sharpness everything looks
so crisp now the way that this is able
to get such dark blacks is because of
the local dimming and that's all due to
the new Alpha 7 processor which is power
ing this entire thing that's how you get
these really dark blacks with no halo
effect I mean like look at that like
this is so
unreal it's like it's like this is real
life I also love how convenient this TV
is pairing webos with this remote is one
of my favorite things I love this about
LG TVs you can select things with these
buttons right here or if you press this
middle scroll button it actually brings
up a little cursor so you can just
select exactly what you want it's super
easy to navigate with a quick card it
makes it super easy to select SCT
various things depending upon what
you're into like live TV gaming music
and you can even go in here at the end
and you can edit them to whatever you'd
like and overall just the whole webos
interface is really convenient and super
easy to navigate so now we're going to
set up the personalized picture Wizard
and this is going to use AI to determine
your personal picture color preferences
so let's check it out and see how this
works let's hit start oh this is so fun
this is like a which one do you like
better okay select up to two images with
preferred picture quality among images
um I like this one I like this one wow
these are all really pretty this one or
this one so this is really cool because
a lot of people don't want to be diving
into the settings adjusting color
preferences when you sometimes don't
really know what you're doing so this is
allowing me to pick the images that I
like that I think look good it'll then
choose all of the settings for me it's
analyzing I like a cool and balanced
picture that is actually pretty accurate
cuz even when I'm doing my own color
grading I like everything to be a little
bit on the cooler side so here's my
before and here's my after it is kind of
hard to tell but you can see especially
in the water this is a little bit Bluer
the colors are slightly a little bit
cooler of a tone even here on this
building and I'm into it okay let's hit
apply now let's dive into the audio
settings with AI Sound Pro so in here
you're able to select the different
settings standard cinema clear voice pro
sports music game Optimizer and then of
course with the Sound Pro this is going
to automatically determine the type of
content that you're watching and change
the sound accordingly so now that we
have our Visual and sound all set up and
customized to our liking let's watch
something and see how it sounds wow okay
now I was actually here in the malds I
have seen this with my eyes and seeing
it and reliving it again here on this
massive TV is pretty
incredible the colors look amazing the
sound is incredible
oh
yeah I'm so hyped about my new gaming
setup like this is going to be so
great super
cool now let's get into gaming since
different games have different visual
needs the game Optimizer allows you to
quickly customize the image to whatever
you're playing it has HDMI 2.1 so you
can get up to 120 frames per second at
high resolutions and it also supports
variable refresh rate technology with
AMD free sync premium another thing that
is so great about this TV is it supports
cloud gaming so all you need is a
compatible controller and you can play
the latest PC games on nvidia's GeForce
Now app so here's your game Optimizer
settings and this lets you change a
bunch of different settings I like that
you can just quickly scroll through here
depending upon the type of game that
you're playing and it will automatically
adjust I also like this it has a dark
room mode so if you're playing in a dark
room it will slightly dim so it's not as
bright for your eyes inside the game
Optimizer this gives you all sorts of
settings that you can adjust depending
upon the type of game that that you're
playing or the way that you like your
display to look while you're playing
games so I kind of like the standard
settings especially for the game that
I'm going to play this is my game robot
Ranch which I'm super hyped about let's
play it and see how it goes all right so
let's go we're going to do a little
speedrun here and see how it looks and
how it's uh that's my own voice super
weird the thing that I do like about
this is it has a low latency mode and
this is especially crucial if you're
playing first person shooter games oh I
got run over by the pest so low latency
is super crucial especially in first
person shooter games because you don't
want to have a lot of controller lag or
screen input lag and this is working
pretty well so far A little dip
huh no okay yay
pH oh yeah this is running perfectly
this is the first time I've played it on
a big screen this is awesome I've been
having so much fun checking out this TV
and I'm so obsessed with the game
Optimizer settings especially for my
gaming room this is so perfect but of
course I do play a lot of video games
just right here at my desk but what's
really fun about this is I can also turn
around and play on this massive 75 in
display and I can even watch all sorts
of content on it as well overall I'm
really happy with this TV and it's such
a nice upgrade for my gaming room thank
you guys so much for watching I hope you
guys enjoyed this video If you want to
get more information about this TV I
will put a link in the description and
if you have any questions feel free to
leave those in the comments below and
I'll see you guys in the next next video
bye